gaming phones powerful chipsets
beautiful screens and booming audio are
just a few traits that make these
handheld monsters worth every penny and
we are going to fit two of our favorites
hit to hit the Rog Phone 7 Ultimate is
really that phone in the mobile gaming
sphere it's got the best thermal
management I've felt with the aeroactive
cooler 7 and external cooling fan that
doubles as a Gamepad and the aeroactive
bottle that opens a flap on the phone to
get the air active cooler a more direct
access to the chipset's heatsink the sky
is the limit when it comes to playing
games for hours comfortably and without
worrying about your phone overheating
however the rear Magic 8 Pro in my
opinion is one of rg's biggest
competitors having slowly moved out the
ladder of gaming phone rankings recently
they too have their own air triggers and
an inbuilt fan that actually works which
is pretty much a dream come true for
anyone who doesn't want to attach an
external cooler on their commute to work
both phones are an even ground specs
wise because they both are on Snapdragon
8 gen 3 processes they both have adrenal
7 faulties for the gpus 5G connectivity
and stunning AMOLED screens before we
get into it this channel is supported by
Brands who help us improve our content
and keep us going so stay around for the
sponsored message if you're looking for
a laptop that has both power and
portability look no further than the
Asus Zenbook 14x OLED it features a
large 70 watt hour battery and stunning
Nano Edge 14.5 inch 2.8k 120 hertz OLED
display powered by the latest 13th gen
Intel Core I9 CPU and RTX 3050 GPU all
packed in a thin 16.9 mm chassis that
only weighs 1.5 kilograms so you can
stay focused at work or play for more
information check out asus.com
the only difference is specs wise
between the Rog Phone 7 Ultimate and new
BS red Magic 8 Pro is the more premium
Hardware in the Rog phone 7. like it's
32 megapixel front facing camera however
I do have some comments about the camera
which we'll get into later on with that
being said the key is still the cost of
each device and the red magic April
offers the most bang for your buck as
far as price the performance goes the
Rog Phone 7 and Phone 7 Ultimate cost us
1 100 and US 1 550 respectively note
that the phone 7 does not have the air
active portal and the cooler 7 must be
purchased separately the red Magic 8 Pro
costs us 649 the RG Phone 7 Ultimate has
16 gigs of RAM and 512 gigs of storage
while the red Magic 8 Pro that we have
has 12 gigs of RAM and 256 gigs of
storage and it runs with magic OS on top
of Android 13. however I do have my
gripes with the red magic OS because as
of this video the red Magic 8 Pro does
not meet Google security requirements
for some reason even though all the
previous writ magic 7 does meet them so
you can't set up contactless payment for
Google pay for now this is a deal
breaker for some of you out there if
you're in a habit of using a phone for
Wireless payments the other thing is
that the UI for the rear Magic 8 Pro is
inconsistent with its language settings
most of the time it's in English but
then you get bits of Mandarin here and
there and I can't change any of that in
the settings so I hope that gets fixed
sometime soon the Rog Phone 7 and 7
Ultimate here has a few key differences
as I mentioned before this is the Aero
active portal and the additional air
active cooler this might be the toughest
buying decision for some as the extra
cooling accessories do Boost the game's
performance and experience overall and
I'd recommend getting the Rog Phone 7
Ultimate Edition right off the bat go
big or go home as they say let's talk
Aesthetics and build quality they're
both extremely Sleek phones with two
opposing design routes with Rog having
much more rounded edges compared to the
rip magic and the inclusion of the
customizable P AMOLED screen which has
been one of the coolest things on the
Rog phone so far the red magic has
lights on the back that are reactive to
your videos music and games if you
choose to enable them in the settings
foreign
[Applause]
ultimate had an option for a black
colorway like it does for the base Rog
Phone 7 but that's just a me thing also
the other thing is that the front-facing
camera is below the screen of the red
Magic 8 Pro which Let its beautiful
notchless 6.8 inch screen really shine
on the display front the red Magic 8 Pro
runs 116 by 2480 pixels and for the Rog
Phone 7 Ultimate 1080 by 2448 pixels so
you've got slightly more real estate on
the red magic however in terms of
refresh rate you've got 120 hertz on the
rear Magic 8 Pro and 865 Hertz on the
Rog Phone 7 Ultimate do you need an
extremely high refresh rate for mobile
gaming most Gamers on phones are casual
gamers and most games by default support
60fps unless you're slightly more
hardcore than you go out of your way to
get pubg running 90 FPS and there are
few games out there that actually do
support 120hz let alone 135 Hertz 120
hertz is more than enough without being
super nitpicky about the subtleties of
performance they're both great looking
displays and the games play out better
than intended because they're gaming
phones whatever you play is going to
look and feel good they're both very
comfortable in hand with a good amount
of real estate to get a grip around the
phones comfortably the Roja is a slight
Edge because of its rounded edges it
allows your trigger fingers to grip
around the edges totally compared to the
rip magix 8 design so that's a point to
Rog also again style points for the
piano display I really can't get enough
of that because it is such a great
conversation it's out there in a room
full of playing backed phones don't get
me wrong the real magic 8 Chic black
Tech back is classic but the red
Magic 8 Pro void Edition on the other
hand would even be aesthetic playing
field with its transparent back now on
to their gaming companion apps and
performance before we get into the
software there is a bit of Hardware that
the red Magic 8 Pro does differently
which is the inclusion of a dedicated
slider on the phone for gaming that
takes you directly into the gaming Hub
anytime it's cool and the red adds a
nice contrast to the phone but
ultimately it's quite the gimmick the
Rog Phone 7 Ultimate doesn't have that
of course but it has Armory crate and
the one thing RMG does slightly better
in terms of gaming hubs is the Armory
crit categorizes games based on their
supported refresh rates and if they
support gamepads performance obviously
the Rog with 16 gigs of RAM and 165hz
refresh rate would beat out the red
magic on paper but the reality is that
they both play well regardless both
phones allow games more space to perform
better with the Rog Phone 7 Ultimate
giving slightly more performance hit
room thanks to its larger Ram if you
want to compare numbers re-ran 3D Mark
and geekbench 6 benchmarks on these
phones so here are the results it's no
mystery that the Rog will be the cooler
phone by 5 degrees thanks to its game
Cool 7 cooling system however I believe
with the additional red call to
co-processor on the red Magic 8 Pro the
red magic is the most stable between the
two phones the Rog Beast may have a lot
stronger with higher numbers on the
initial Loops for 3D mark But the red
magic finishes the race with a higher
and more consistent Loop score that's
all for 3dmark and now on to geekbench
6. of course the Rog Phone 7 Ultimate
will build their magic 8 Pro out of the
water with its additional RAM so there's
that gaming wise besides the attention
to ergonomics that the Rog Phone 7
Ultimate office they both feel the same
when it comes to Performance I haven't
noticed significant frame rate drops
with more intensive games like Genji
impact or Diablo Immortal even during my
playthroughs which you can check out in
our gaming test videos check the link in
the top right for my thoughts on the RG
phones and ultimate when it comes to
gaming now with Armory crate and red
Magic's game hub both proof useful to
enhance the experience and so does Game
Genie it has a couple tools such as
Scout mode which inverts the colors so
you can spot enemies in games like Call
of Duty more easily but you can't use it
in say Genji impact so only specific
tools are enabled for certain games the
red magic equivalent however has even
more tools or plugins as they are called
that can only be used for certain games
as well such as auxiliary lines so you
can set your character's attack ranges
heck even a note segments so that you
can review notes and tips and tricks
while playing RPG games like genjin and
so much more casual mobile Gamers like
my cell phone really look into putting a
Crosshair on screen or enabling Scout
mode but if you're into having a massive
advantage over your online opponents
both phones possess the tools to wreck
everyone in every way not to mention you
have air triggers that are Uber
responsive so you already have a huge
Advantage especially for fps's not all
phones are created equal and if you have
the means for an advantage why not the
other thing to take into account is the
inclusion of the air active cooler 7 in
the Rog Phone 7 ultimates package and
its air active portal which allows for
efficient airflow when the cooler is
attached the red Magic 8 Pro of course
does not have any of this but it does
have its internal cooling fan that can
be set to an auto or maximum mode okay
just to show you that the fan actually
does work I'm going to be putting the
microphone on the fan vent
[Applause]
that's the boot up sound and here the
fan this is on its maximum mode
you're getting a more well-rounded
package with the Rog Phone 7 Ultimate
off the bat but in the case of the rip
Magic 8 Pro you could definitely just
order one of the coolers or get a third
party external fan and a set of
compatible triggers mobile works for
real magic fans yes but is it really a
deal breaker
definitely not so all in all they're
even on the game ground to me at least
now for the cameras the RG Phone 7
Ultimate has a wide 15 megapixel F 1.9
and Ultra wide 13 megapixel F 2.2 120
degree camera and a macro 5 megapixel F
2.0 the red Magic 8 Pro has a wide 50
megapixel F 1.9 and Ultra wide angle 8
megapixel F 2.2 that also goes 120
degrees any macro 2 megapixel F 2.4 lens
on paper the Rog beats the red magic but
with a real world test you'd be
surprised on the main camera A1 Time
Zone on both of them the focus on the
red magic works better and the colors
and details you get to pass the Rog the
ultra wides and longer are the highest
zooms the red magic being 0.5 times and
10 times and the Rog at 0.6 times and 8
times both aren't great but between the
two I'd say the Rog does a better job in
these areas that's it however the Rog
works better with low light as you can
see in these images and with the macro
you get more detail of the Rog than the
root magic the red Magic 8 Pro came of
the ak-30fps while the Rog Phone 7
Ultima can go to ak24fps however both
phones can shoot in 4k 60 and 30 FPS and
they look pretty good however the red
magic well stabilization is non-existent
and I think even if you throw on a warp
stabilizer it won't look as stable
lastly in terms of audio the Rog Phone 7
Ultimate takes the win because of its
inbuilt subwoofer which makes explosions
and gunfire and pretty much everything
that much punchier compared to the red
Magic 8 Pro and I think I've covered
pretty much all the points I needed to
it is a fierce fight between the Rog
Phone 7 Ultimate and the red Magic 8 Pro
both of these phones are almost similar
if not for the difference in the amount
of RAM and after considering all things
I really feel that the red matching 8
Pro would still be worth my money if I
had disposable income I would definitely
get the Rog .7 ultimate without a second
thought not only because it is more
powerful and cooler looking phone but
because it is available worldwide and on
major e-commerce sites like Amazon
however the rip Magic 8 Pro is only
available for shipping to 42 countries
directly from red magic and you can't
find it on Amazon at the time of this
video still even though it's been
released much earlier than the Rog
having used the both of them as daily
drivers they both function from
messaging people surfing social media
sites and watching videos but in the
case of the red Magic 8 Pro the absence
of Google pay due to the presence of red
Magic's own OS that isn't Google
Certified it's a deal breaker for me
because I want to use contactless
payment and the sometimes odd placement
of engine that you can't change it's a
little bit jarring gaming phones have
really come a long way and Rog Nails it
with every release with Brands like
Nubia already magic slowly rising up it
really does make it an exciting Market
to watch because you never know what new
innovation in mobile tech is going to
come around the corner but the real
question is what do you think if you
could choose between the Rog Phone 7
Ultimate and the red Magic game pro
which would you choose and why let me
know in the comments below and don't
forget to follow us on all of our
socials right here to keep up with the
latest news and content we put down and
if you like what you're watching leave a
like and maybe subscribe to us it helps
the channel a lot if you want to see
more stuff check this out
[Music]
foreign